a
love
goo
今日は
我々がやっている
森の音
原生自然の森の音をインターネットで
ライブで配信するというプロジェクトに
ついてお話しします
これはライブで配信しているだけではなく
録音をしてそのまま公開しています
ですので皆さんの電車の中で聞いて
自分の
スマホなんかにダウンロードして持ち運ぶ
こともできます
こういうことが起こるとどういうことに
なるのか
という風に考えていく
のに全9感覚というものをちょっと考え
ました
それについてちょっと今日は紹介したいと
思います
えっとこれは
日本の中央部の埼玉県の奥秩父にある東京
大学の
ebony の中です
ここは2種類のウナの木が
湯煎している天然林で
長い期間をかけて生態の調査が行われてい
ます
でブナの木は非常に高いので一番上の状態
を観察するためにこのような鉄塔が建って
います
この最上部に
このような
ビデオカメラと
マイクロホンを設置して
1995年から毎日指導で6人で記録する
といったようなことをやっております
この6人っていうことでですね
すぐ資格で鳥が鳴いたりするので
鳥の専門家に診てもらうと
方に鳥が止まって泣くような
声とか
小さい羽ばたき音も聞こえてびっくりする
そうです
でこの越冬へカメラで撮った映像なんです
けれども
現地の気温とか
雨量などとデータと一緒にちょっと編集し
て環境教材を作ってみています
見ていただいているのはこれブナの
2002年なんですけれど
ブナの木は10年に1回ぐらいしか実が
つかないんです
で観ていただいているこの実が付いてる
2002年
の会春の映像をちょっと見てください
はいえーと次にちょっと天井スピーカーで
聞こえることがある音だけちょっと聞いて
ほしいんです
ええええええ
8とにはとりやセミやー
数や雨の音が聞こえますとバラバラがこの
資格をで観察するとついつい
そこから何か知識を得ようと思って観て
しまいますけれども音はもっと感覚的に
素直に聞けるし現場の様子と
自分の身の回りの
雨の雰囲気1例えば東京が女でしたら同じ
雨なんだなーとか向こう腫れてるんだ
いう風に自分の身の回りの延長として
引くことができるって言うことに少し
気づいたんですね
もう一つ音を聞いてください
これは
干支6月の
日1ボス後の真っ暗になった
長野県の志賀高原の森の音です
ちょっと気になる方のために
8 bully ビタキっていうのはで
ギュって泣いてもギアをガールのカエルの
声
それから9件キュンキュンっていうのは
夜行性の夜高
最後に綺麗になっているのがこるりなん
です
こんな風に
想像
6人のマイクなんでいろんな性対応も含め
て聞こえるということです
これ
インターネットでライブで配信しているの
でスマホで聴くことができます
今
まさにこの志賀高原の護衛
この分
風ノートが使えます
季節が季節ですのでこんな感じです
はい
6人のマイクということとそれからそう
簡単には行けない原生林の中
ましてはよるともあれば誰も経験すること
はなかなか難しいです
それがライブで
インターネットに流れていてしかもその
レコード過去録音されたものが公開されて
いると
いうことで今の音も含めて過去のものを
聞きたければ
種もしくはライブを聞きたければサイバー
フォレストで検索していただければ
サイトが出てきますのでぜひ試してみて
ください
さてえっとインターネットに森の音が流れ
てるって言うことはどういうことかって
言うとですね私があの朝聞きながら
ツイッターで
今
森の音が流れてるんで聞いてみてください
というふうにつぶやいたりするんですね
それで例えば2012年の2月です
まあ冬の森の中なんですがこんな音が
聞こえます
これはのキス好きのと怒怒怒怒っていう
ドラミングって言うんですけれどもそう
いう音がしたこの直後にですね
次の音を聞いてください
突然聞いたこともないぐらい大きな
ただドっていう音が聞こえ
それからそういうものが一しばらく続いて
ですねその67分後にはこの音が聞こえ
ました
えっとその時の
twitter のログがこれです
私はいつものようにライブなので木次の音
を聞いてくださいとは言えないので何分か
聴いていれば聞こえるかもみたいなことを
つぶやいていたら突然大きな音がしたので
なんだなんだって言うよということでです
ね
ほんの数人でツイッターで聞いたわけです
そしているうちに
第どこまで聞こえてきたらまたパソコンに
戻ってきたとかですね
そういうツイッターをすると皆さん
フォロワーが言いますのでどんどん拡散し
ていくだけですね
いつもだったらまあせいぜい34人で聞い
ているものがこの時は
最後は19人ぐらいが同時に聞いていた
言ったような状態になります
そしてこの録音のファイルを専門家に送っ
たところこれはオオアカゲラと融合型の
キツツキの
なあ針争いの一部刺繍ですと言われてあぁ
そう hang はっていうことがわかっ
たんですね
こういうことで私はその
ソーシャルメディアっていうふうに今言わ
れてますけど
インターネットの中に人間の新しい関係で
コミュニティをつくるだけでなくそこに
原生自然法そのまま持ち込めるのではない
かと
自然も
ソーシャルメディアの一員として
入り込めるという風に考えています
話は変わりますけど
あるになったのに鳥の声がしないという
寓話で始まるレイチェルカーソンの沈黙の
春来遺書があります
当時のケネディー大統領は農薬問題
について研究を開始するように
言ったそうです
では
支部の森の
音はどうでしょう
最初に2004年の
6月繁殖期の日の出のちょっと前の
4:15の音をちょっと聞いてもらいます
ではその10年後の去年の6月のことです
一番手前で泣いてたのは赤肌という鳥なん
ですけどその後ろで何種類かの鳥が賑やか
そうに鳴いている様子がわかって10年で
そんなに変わらないんだなあって
いうことを今回準備してご紹介しようと
思ったんですけど
ちょっとびっくりしたことがありまして
これです
これは今聴いていただいた音の波形なん
ですが4時15分前後30分ぐらい
ちょっとグラフ化しました
上は2004年でしたは2014
4:15だけ見るとですね
同じようなんですけど他の時間帯は実は
2014年ほとんど
静かな感じなんですね
2004年はずーっと泣いているうん
って思って
去年のその前の日と次の次の日一日3日4
日を同じように作っているから
なんだかやっぱり2004年とちょっと
違ってな
こんなことをは思うとじゃあもっと他の
ここに鳥が移動したのか
そのと都市の気象とかですね色んな減少で
たまたまその時になかったのかいろいろ
思うようになるわけです
あそうやってどんどんどんどんいろんな
知識を確かめていくというようなことが
できるのかな
use
さて我々は今このライブのモニタリング
ポイント全国8カ所に置いています
中には無人島のミスで揚げ鶏の営巣地など
に置いているんですけれども
これは岩手県の大槌湾に設置しているもの
です
最初に支部で設置した
大きなものと比べると非常にコンパクトで
ですねマイクと希少センサーと web
かめ
ここは現地にもうすでに津波の被災後です
けれども電源もネットワークもありますの
で24時間配信しています
これは同じく東京大学が北海道に持って
いる森の中の原生林の中です
ここにこんな形で設置しているんですが
これはソーラーとバッテリーだけでええ
あと衛星のネットワークを使って動かして
います
ですので時間を電源を入れたり切ったりし
ながら1日トータル7時間経度しか配信的
なんですけど今ま
こんな形で行くことのできない原生自然の
音を自分のみの前の音の延長
として感じられるのではないかという風に
考えてみたりしています
ということはまあ
日本の中に8カ所やってるんですけども
例えば
軽度ごとにですねこういったものをずっと
並べていくと
いつも日の出前後後時間とか2時間の
森の様子ラリー自然の様子あをずっと引き
続けることができるわけですね
これは決して一人でやろうということでは
全くないんです非常にカジュアルに
ちょっとした時に何か気になるなと思って
弾いてみる
街を聞いてみるこちらも料金
これっておととしと何か違うかなとか
じゃあ100年前は降ったのって言っても
c 赤い部があれば
もっともっと直感的に地球全体のことが
分かるのではないか
いう風に考えます
ここからはお願いっていうかあの
なんですがこれはですね例えば去年の12
月の私のパソコンの上の画面です
web ページをいっぱいななこ被害て8
カ所あるんですけど7個開いて
一つ一つのページが一つの場所の画像と
気温とかのデータと
それから選べば好きなとこのライブん引く
と言ってのことができます
データはですね
今
今年だと多分あ去年ですと音 love
えっ1年間20テラバイトぐらいのデータ
音声とか画像とかデータがたまるんです
けど
これをどうやってまぁスマホのアプリとか
いろんなものと組み合わせてもっと遠隔の
自然を
ドラえもんでいう裏山みたいな形でですね
身近にふと感じた時に
いて
sns で共有するということができない
かな
いったようなことを考えているんですけど
なかなかやっぱ現場が一番優先ですので
我々としてはここに相手を出してよなもの
を作り上げるというのは非常に難しい
もです
でも
あっちょっとこで聞いてくださいこんな形
でデスクトップで気になれば
選んだよね
くん
最初にちょっと流れてたのは岩手県の
大槌町で
いわゆる復興の工事の音です昼
その後は
12月の支部の音を誓っ
こういったものとですねあとこういう
タブレット pc にデザインしたウェブ
ページを用意して
家に帰って充電ついでにこんな箱に入れて
ですね
森で窓っていうふうに名付けているんです
が
ガラすぐ開けると
願い部分が聞こえ
チネルと
という非常に単純が
でもやっぱタブレットのボタンを押して
聞くのと全然違うんですね
これは今日はの展示の方に持ってきてい
ますのでぜひ試してみてください
はいえーと今日はこの
全球感覚という意味でですね
音で入ることによって変に視覚に頼ると
つい解釈してしまったりするので音であれ
ば非常にカジュアルに
そんなに
考え込まなくても聞くことができて
自分の身の回りの延長のように
遠くの森の音が
聞けるわけですね
この前急感覚っていうのは
我々
とに私なんかもうすでに遅くてですねこれ
から生まれてくる日
人たちが
5歳とか6歳になったぐらいからもうそう
いう変革の音を自由に弾いたり確認したり
できるっていう人たちが10年20年と
減る中で
身につくもの
なので先ほど10年前の音と10年後の音
を比べて違うとか同じとか言いましたけど
そこをちゃんと10年間生きて経験してみ
のマギキストークがそうだと言われている
人と
その好き生まれてないけど10年前稿で
さらに何十年前こうだったと言われて理解
するのはちょっと違うと思うんですね
そこの部分はインターネットの中に自然を
持ち込むことで
これからどんどん解決できるのではないか
と
いう風に考え
そうすることで地球環境問題についても
もっと感覚的に地球全体を捉えて
報道できるようになるのではないかと提起
し
ご静聴ありがとうございました